want to talk about economic cascade
failure
so you may have seen these stories over
the past few months of like people
putting up signs saying we all quit
right
you you were just mentioning that for
the past year so people are getting paid
more not to work so why would they work
i think that plays a role in people not
working so what happens is we had a
story recently another one where it's
like sign appears on a restaurant we've
been working for a month straight with
no days off there's not enough people
here so we all quit sorry for the
inconvenience
when you have a restaurant with 10
people
and that allows you to have rotating
shifts of part-time workers people get
their days off
when three of them end up quitting for
whatever reason leaving for whatever
reason
and now you only you you have less
substantially less staff people have to
pick up shifts
then you say look we have no one else we
need you to come in and then they say i
can't work this many hours i quit
it's a cascade failure where the more
people who quit
the more people will quit meaning more
people will quit yeah so even though
we've ended the covet unemployment
benefits you ever you ever you ever have
like a drain like a thing of water and
you're like draining the tub and you
swirl it with your finger for fun to
make that spiral that's what we did
that's what the democratic establishment
the governors and many republicans did
they decided that as the the economy was
being shuttered they would swirl the
water as fast they could to try and kick
start that that little whirlpool to to
kick off
as soon as they got a certain amount of
people to quit it it's ignition it
becomes self-sustainable but a better a
better way to put it is they had the
stick in the wood and they were doing a
little thing to get the stick to
friction and they were like we just need
ignition once we get to the point where
we generate enough friction for the
business people will quit once people
keep quitting it becomes a
self-sustaining collapse a cascade
failure of economics and now we're going
to see prices go up i'm seeing i saw
more people today post photos of empty
store shelves yeah yeah that's crazy to
me that has been going on for so long
but you know where i go makes sense when
they talk about a great reset about
people consuming too much and i'm like
well
here it is
people people are going to wake up one
day to 10 milk
and that's when things get crazy so and
it's happening at a bad time because
winter always exacerbates economic
problems right you have you have
transportation problems because of snow
because of ice because of cold um things
are just harder to to to to to maintain
in in winter um
so prices are going to skyrocket not to
mention
oil prices gas prices electricity prices
heating prices right so it's going to be
bad they i actually on the on the drive
here they were already talking on the
news about they have noticed uh an
increase in hoarding tendencies again at
big box stores toilet paper paper towels
there's nothing causing it there's no
there's no something on the horizon but
people just feel it this is the the
fascinating thing absolutely people who
are paying attention the people who are
paying attention are feeling it and
people are
people are doing it um so yeah we're
headed to some very very very dark times
you want to know how dark it is let me
just pull up this story right here two
men arrested in new zealand for
smuggling kfc into coveted lockdown
auckland okay so not necessarily the
same thing as economic failure but but
come on this is the psychotic nightmare
dystopia story you never thought you'd
see smuggling kfc why is kfc banned
why can't you have kfc central i don't
know what is that to do with covington
maybe like they were in an area that
you're not allowed to are they in a
quarantined area because their their
quarantines were geographic like you are
not allowed to take out his band take
out his band what why because it might
have covert on it okay
so look i highlighted this just to show
hell is happening when when they set
policies and play in into in motion that
create a cascade failure a collapse
this is just another example of the
absurdity of the rules that make no
sense that will just cause people to
lose their minds yeah covet doesn't live
out in the environment for very long i
mean that's pretty i mean
but that's that's besides the point the
point i'm saying is people in government
don't know don't care they're just like
burn it down
just whatever it takes to make people go
crazy and burn it down middle-class
people seeing the prices we went to the
store the other day we were like we want
to get some charcuterie some meats and
cheeses we had the shopping cart maybe
about 20 full and it was four hundred
dollars yes
i get it you know cheese and meat can be
costly but
a year ago we filled up a whole cart
including our standard selection of
meats and cheese we're not buying like
fancy you know french imported meats
like regular salami and stuff we would
fill up the whole car for 400 bucks i
remember a year ago we filled the cart
and we had like beans and rice and meat
and cheese and milk and i was like wow
400 for this that's crazy now it's like
the car's barely full and i'm like what
is happening
i have been photo documenting my grocery
trips because every single time i go i
spend about the same amount and every
time it gets smaller this last time i
filled the seat that the kid sits in
with the food that i was buying for
myself for a week and it was like eighty
dollars and i was like this is not what
i used to be able to buy this is insane
and the stores are the shelves are empty
this is something i noticed too there's
no dairy there's very little beef we
couldn't get cream yeah this bothered me
end of the world cream for my coffee and
we went and uh i like heavy cream i
don't like the half and half it's got a
little sugar in it i don't know i want
like fresh cream and we went to the
store over a month not nothing
and so i asked i was like how do you
have none and they're like it just
doesn't come in and i'm like yeah but
you got cheese and ice cream and they
were like i guess you know they're
prioritizing
they're not prioritizing the heavy cream
because it's like a special use case how
many how much like come on if you go to
the store and you want something with
cream you're gonna get milk you're gonna
get cheese you're gonna get yogurt
you're gonna get ice cream heavy
whipping cream is probably one of the
last things people get and not everybody
puts cream in their coffee like that but
when you're doing keto you know things
like that you're like you want to use
fresh heavy cream less sugars less you
know milk particles and stuff they
didn't have it so we had to go to a
different store and we found
a crumbier version that spoiled much
faster
but that that's something that really
freaked me out because aside from the
cream were these little stars they put
up everywhere that said 500 sign-on
bonus
all over the store i put on my instagram
you can watch the video i'm like yo
something's wrong
there's a bunch of some stuff like boy
do they got a lot of canned whipped
cream
but that's like corn syrup that's not
yeah
some of it yeah a lot of it some of it's
good though some of it's well some of
it's okay it depends on what you but i'm
like i just want fresh cream like i want
i want to eat healthy and have clo
i guess if you were to ask someone what
they were going to buy first they'd be
like i'll take the the ready whip being
a whipped cream bottle over the fresh
cream you know what i mean so they are
not prioritizing it or the store wasn't
getting it i went to a couple stores
didn't have it yeah we finally found a
store that did
we got a bunch it didn't last as long
for whatever reason i don't know i'm
like we like the the good organic stuff
i mean we've been doing this as a
country for you could argue almost 400
years or not as a country but as
people on this land
our economy got to a stage of
so well
oiled so supply line genius so it is
really adam smith in operations you know
there's always that expression um
or that a running joke in the economic
world of how many
chinese restaurants can you have on one
block in new york city and the answer is
as many as the market allows right like
like there is no rule like we got to the
point that yeah you could get your heavy
cream your your fresh whipping cream
without even thinking about it because
all these literally millions of
invisible hands were all working
together making things happen and all we
needed was this one big government that
the thought they knew better
for your own good have you ever been
we're never it's going to take another
five years to recover from this i feel
like we're in the rat utopia experiment
you're familiar you guys you guys are
familiar with oh yeah no so we had uh
shane who writes uh for our mysteries
and and tales of intrigue for
timcast.com the new shows we're getting
ready to launch soon the podcast version
and one of the stories he wrote is about
the the rat utopia experiment and the
was it the kurt curtis richter was that
his name i think so yeah the rat
experiment that's the hope experiment
but the right utopia was that he he
created space put the rats in it gave
him unlimited food and water and said do
whatever you want and eventually they
they just
went nuts started killing each other
uh things got really bad there was there
was one group called the beautiful ones
that just groomed themselves and do
nothing else they would all huddle in
the same place just behavior became very
very weird so what you're bringing up
now because i know we mentioned the
right experiment stuff quite a bit but
the point i'm trying to make is the idea
that i'm
put out over the fact i can't snap my
fingers and get my cream it's kind of
insane isn't it
how about back in the day you had to
actually go find a cream salesperson or
a farmer who had a dairy farm and you'd
be like spending a few days or you'd
know who one person was who had it and
you'd be like
you know oh hey honey jim says we we
should be ready to pick up our our uh
our supply of cream you know in three
days when it's ready and you just
couldn't get it because it didn't exist
now we're so used to everything at our
fingertips having an overabundance of
food and unlimited supply of ridiculous
things like cream of all things and
sugar candies and unlimited water and we
are living in that utopia and that is
the problem that unfolds a lot of the
the hyperbolic social ills that the left
likes to say are dividing this country
you know systemic racism and and
militants misogyny and sexism and the
response often is we live in the not to
say that there are not ills in society
we live in the time of such privilege
henry viii could not have imagined a
more opulent lifestyle i know i mean you
just look at how many pillow options you
have
yeah you know like just one
promo code
like the the level of privilege we have
our the the american poor and this is
another thing if you do any
international travel especially to
developing countries or like real this
poverty in impoverished countries which
i have
our poor have better quality of life
than the vast majority then literally
half the world
our poor and and
not to say that we shouldn't make our
poor more prosperous or allow them to
become more prosperous but the level of
prosperity and opulence and comfort we
have is is almost sickening we went to
the mall
and uh i walked in and you get to the
like there's a bunch of the you know
doors and it's like you get to the
middle and there's the
three story so you've got two stories
but that is an even higher dome of glass
and i was like man
if you took someone from like the 1500s
and brought them in they would be like
for what god have you created this
palace like no i'm just buying sneakers
exactly i wanted to get an ice cream
while i was here that's that that is
insane you look at these buildings look
at i tweeted this the other day look at
go to the grocery store and look at how
many orange juice options you have based
upon your tolerance of pulp
and it's like and the people who are
like oh i don't drink pope it's like you
think we're going to abolish fossil
fuels
it's like i only do grove stand no pulp
and
no we're never going to abolish fossil
fuels because your lifestyle dictates
that i like fiji water oh crystal geyser
i don't like this water thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast if you want to see the full
show come back to this channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8pm where you can leave
comments and super chat and we actually
will read your comments on the show
don't forget to like share subscribe and
if you want exclusive members only
content segments you can't get anywhere
else go to timcast.com become a member
and we even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you